well today's figures show that despite
omicron the economy was actually
remarkably resilient we were the fastest
growing economy in the g7 last year and
we're forecast to continue being the
fastest growing economy this year as
well so that shows that our plans for
the economy are working but of course i
know people are concerned about
inflation in particular rising energy
prices now although those are global
challenges where we can make a
difference of course we will act and
that's why last week we announced
significant support to help millions of
families meet those rising bills you're
asking
the poorest and those least able to bear
the cost and not the corporation
generating the profits but let's part
that time now actually
that's really important because i don't
i just actually are simply not right
actually and if you look at how we're
doing this it has been cited by many
independent people as a progressive way
to raise the money and actually no that
you said and that's actually not right
it's not right that the poorest will
bear the burden in fact though six
million people on the lowest incomes
will not will not pay the levy at all
and in fact half of all the revenue
raised from the levy is paid by the top
15
of income tax payers so it is actually a
highly progressive way to raise the
funds
inflation running at seven percent
around the bank of england says now
should employees
uh should employers grant
inflation-based wage increases to
workers surely the people who've given
up so much for so long deserve at very
least their wages to keep up with
inflation well i don't think it's the
government's role to get involved in
conversations between private businesses
and their employees about their wages i
just don't think that's what a
government in this dna should be doing
every company and every set of employees
will be in a different circumstance and
in a free market economy that i believe
in uh it's for all those individual
companies employees to have that
conversation
it's not it's not the government's job
to go and start telling people what they
should be paid i just don't think that's
the right role for the government but if
employers start
offering seven percent inflation-based
inflation-linked pay rises you haven't
got a problem with that you don't worry
about the consequence of banking in
government you know i said i think we
have millions of different companies in
this country all with different sets of
employees and needs for employment some
are growing some are shrinking some are
short of staff some are not got a few
seconds i thought have you received your
questionnaire from the metropolitan
police yet no are you expecting to
receive one uh no are you worried about
it i don't know i believe you may have
broken the rules no knockdown rules no
okay
does the prime minister have your
confidence the prime minister has my
total support
thank you